[Music]
in point proven news oh yeah it's
actually proof pointment down to prove
Putin submitted by get this bread get
this bread and invited me I was thinking
like a toast okay no so it's a loaf of
bread hello it's a carbohydrate a
hipster claimed the company falsely used
his image only to find out the picture
is of another hipster ah that is a body
it's incredible well was it a bearded
guy with like glasses and a freaking
plaid shirt or something he's so
unoriginal up plaid and beard right can
you guess anymore I was eating that it
was a homeless person smog look on his
face yeah nailed all of it and II
thought it was him south but it wasn't
even his another marine five guy not to
getting image stock image yes
good-looking dude yeah great eyebrows
well they being whoever thought this guy
he was that guy he's good-looking
yeah he wasn't as hipster guy thought it
was him it's actually pretty busted and
in his head he thinks he looks like that
guy everyone's like no you're [ __ ]
busted he's like 80 pounds like heavier
yeah it's like shorter can barely grow a
beard like I can't believe this
[ __ ] use my image without my
life my licensing like that I know I
like that narrative better me too
yeah so this there was this article
posted MIT Technology Review and it was
called the hipster effect by anti
conformists always end up looking the
same you know what's so funny is all
these people that are like ATS I you
know like anti society anti like regular
norm [ __ ] they all been looking the same
since like a long time ago since Hot
Topic dude well that's a good entire
party looking like hippies since like
the 60s that's like what grandpa used to
look like like punk like punk is old now
it's like 40 years plus like you're not
that new and edgy so they're calling it
the hip
your effect which is a counter to
intuitive phenomenon in which people who
oppose mainstream culture all end up
looking the same and so they were just
like looking into this and like how does
this happen like how long does it take
and all that stuff right and then that's
when they got this furious email from
this guy saying like how dare you like
you didn't get my permission to use my
image I'm gonna sue you for defamation
because apparently like he's keeping
being called the hipsters
he's so hipster that you can't even
classify him as a hipster because that's
putting him in a category yeah money
doesn't he know like if you remember his
way I never took a picture on a letter
right yeah well he ended up just proving
the point of this article that all
hipsters look to see like he couldn't
even tell himself apart that's hilarious
they actually contacted getting images
to make sure like okay we got to make
sure like this isn't the same guy and
then they came back to them saying like
no this is a different guy what the [ __ ]
is MiG doing dude they're doing a study
to show that all hipsters look the same
I [ __ ] love this [ __ ] like [ __ ]
articles they're trolling man ha take
Jesus was a hipster yo he started that
trend it started it he's a squatter
Jesus was a squatter there's also Magee
well I just want to hear uh their
rebuttal like bro this isn't even you
like I want to hear that back and forth
all you hear him get motive yes that's
what I want oh did ya I love edge lords
that think they're so unique but then
there's like a million of them out there
so that it's not that it's not that
unique what's that Jordan I want to use
that in my vocabulary like someone who's
like always going extra about how edgy
they are like like they're trying to
prove how different they are I got to
that I can't think of an edge Lord
without thinking of edging so then it
becomes a very different edge that's
what I was doing
you work yourself up sexually but then
you stop yeah and then you work yourself
up and you stop then you work yourself
up and stop to torture yourself that's
what I do it there all the time
yeah that's how you looked at the global
the mat and the wall that's just to stop
himself from coming I don't know what
he's I don't want you are and I don't
want to come too fast and you're still
far away from it okay so I taught you
that Smith highway to the dangerzone was
having sex yeah wait so you look at a
map and it stops you from coming back in
the old place our old place we had a map
above our bed and then so when I have to
really restrain myself from ejaculation
I look up at it I'm like oh okay so
there's Mongol he's above China and then
Venezuela's over there I started looking
and it kind of distracts me a little bit
I thought yeah you had a fear of like
geography like it triggers me a kid Oh
traveling so fast cool tsa I'm still
trying to stay erect and stimulated that
makes total sense I don't get fearful
and you don't want a bustle not too
early no no no no no many edge Awards
here oh are you in that group no it's
just thing you know trying extra hard to
be hardcore and different you're doing a
great job over there yeah you definitely
look like you're you're on your way look
like I'm like a [ __ ] Hollywood
Highland Michael Jackson personnel oh
thank you you're welcome
you know I think I just do things
without thinking things through and then
I commit but you know I went to a when I
went to a university yes I did go to
college and got my bachelor's I know
it's hard to know and it's hard to
freaking understand but anyways when I
was there there's a high school there's
arts there's a hot there's a high school
there there's a art school
that's like all like these art high
school students that are all large
students in the arts right right I just
look at his mouth yeah if all these art
students are so unique and different
right
why are they all just the same I just
pictured that I'm sitting next to this
guy on the bus right now I'm like [ __ ] I
gotta take this guy the whole [ __ ]
ride art art students go to art school
he's already talking about some that
damnit who goes to the art school art
students and that's my that's I want to
prove a point not right now when you're
really different pointing and when
you're really when you're really trend
setting like me you're too [ __ ] cool
and nobody wants to follow that sure
that's why everyone just follows a
little herd like that oh yeah they think
they're different [ __ ] you haven't met
different
I'll show you different go to skid row
nobody's arguing with you how was it the
pharmacy trying to get pain [ __ ] for
when I was on kidney stones and there
was a guy behind me and just out of
nowhere he's like I'm so sick people
[ __ ] us what's the context man like
what were they doing I know what it's
talking about
he's probably talking about the high
prices of [ __ ] pharmaceuticals or
he's not getting a pill that he wants
good event or we were also aligned for a
long time could have been good at
laughing but yeah he knew I love that's
why I was perfect thank you I know
okay anyway so then this so one of the
guys that was involved with this article
which ended up tweeting this whole pizza
mazing and that's how we know about this
story it's by I wish I could just
[ __ ] hear their rebuttal cuz if I was
a person replying to this [ __ ] I
would be so happy I'd be like typing
like well first of all you know oh man I
wish I could watch that black shirt
5-5-5 has has left the chat that's what
that's what happened yeah at the very
right what's that reply gonna be is he's
just gonna you just left the chat but he
didn't respond I don't think so it's too
embarrassing dude this reminds me I was
at a Super Bowl party
remember what Bruno Mars played the
Super Bowl halftime show yeah
and he was just [ __ ] spectacular like
he was just great yeah and it was like
fun and good and [ __ ] I mean this is one
guy at the party who's just like I just
don't like Bruno Mars and I'm like
[ __ ] like what up yeah [ __ ] are like
what the absolute [ __ ] man like honest
to god like you're just trying to be
different here that's what I'm saying
you objectively you cannot just like
Bruno Mars he's so cool and exactly
you're right
and he makes such good music there's
no way you cannot like munawar's it's
like sigh they've done studies I don't
like him at all and if you don't like
Bruno Mars you just don't understand
music that's what I'm saying I hate him
you know what does remind you yeah jeah
don't do it don't do it you she's trying
to be an edge lord you're being a jerk
because to me it's unequivocal you can't
even deny it you know what this reminds
me of underground rap lovers or just
under ground ground culture lovers
alright they love underground so much so
that they don't want their artists to
succeed and get into the maze yeah it
mainstream oh yeah you're selling up
that [ __ ] needs to eat yes your
shitty as paying five dollars for a
concert is not [ __ ] paying the bill I
always think about like how did
underground stuff like spread before the
Internet well do what I mouths word
about word of mouth taste it was like
mainly people that because in that case
for me in my little bubble I'm like what
you can only get as far as like the end
of your city I guess like how far can
you really start to worry touring yeah
you just started heating them up or you
can send out your demo to the different
clubs like hey this is my music I'd like
to be at your venue and then that's why
those guys outside of rouse are always
passing out their CDs because they're
doing it they go do you like hip-hop
do you like hip-hop no I do not I like
Girl Scout cookies [ __ ] where are
they today don't like you're mad do you
like hip-hop I'm just trying to make it
in this world man even till this day
then when you say another like will you
have a bus a day anyway man and I'm
always like I don't know if that has
ever made someone turn around and be
like I want to buy it now like you don't
I mean like you know what I do like
hip-hop and since you told me god bless
you we got a connection here man I gotta
listen to your music now exactly they
still do remember I was doing that
albertson's the handicapped rap group to
hit me up see they still a passing
handicap rap group I told you about the
handicapped Bloods I didn't know they
were handicapped no so there's actually
blood yeah I was an al person yeah I
remember and then they're like far away
and I saw these two dudes it was full
red
like red hurry red pants everything with
what they get with the gangster lean
walking I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm like
damn I thought the 90s were over I
didn't people were still that bald with
like their colors like that then he
comes up to me and he goes hey do you
like hip-hop and I'm like oh it's
alright I think I just want to show you
my mixtape and he's I want to tell what
I'm all about
he goes I'm handicapped my boys
handicapped a whole crews handicapped
and then he showed me even his sweater
he turned around he had the handicaps
that ball so they were special bloods
yeah he goes I'm missing fingers he's
not been shot at and then he's like I'm
trying I'm trying to represent for the
disabled people's so he got handicapped
from like gang wars probably probably
something like that and then he was just
telling me like all his songs about
handicap stuff he was like if you buy my
album it will go to whatever like the
things that I'm doing
veteran group organization I just told
him I you know what like just hold onto
your CD I'm like I'll support your cause
and I just giving 20 bucks I kept it I
picture I saw in front of the freaking
doorway of the grocery store you had one
guy with Down syndrome one guy with like
no legs one guy in a wheelchair
and I and it's like one blind dude and
you had the cane and it's like the whole
good like that lame dude right now yeah
that's what we're the whole crew and
they're like hey you like rap music and
then they're pitching no these guys look
actually look kind of scary and tell you
you walk up to them and you see these
like missing fingers and stuff like that
that's kind of scary but - it makes it
scary but then when they turn around
then you see the handicap symbol on the
back yeah they let your uniforms booty
music was like like a roll deep in my
wheelchair or some [ __ ] like yeah he's
Rosie I wish that they actually played
the music though like have a little
boombox and play the music so I get a
sample of it cuz they always do the
story life story thing and I don't care
I want to hear your music yeah like I
don't want to buy it because I don't
know if I like your music
she should be playing the [ __ ] saying
[Music]